- Do you understand that
everybody can create now?
At scale?
- Yeah, I do I do.
- At a level that is so unprecedented.
There were so many gatekeepers
when you got in the Hollywood game
that had to say, "Yes, you have a chance."
Now, we all have a chance
and yet people are
still not making content
to live their happiest
and dream-filled life
out of an anonymous comment,
that says they're ugly.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, it's 321?
- Yep.
- Episode 321
of The AskGaryVee Shows
and I'm super excited because, you know
what's really interesting is
every time I bring up Brian's name
or if it's brought up and I talk about
knowing him and liking
him or things that nature.
We were just off air,
except if you're on the live
and Brad was saying,
"You know the kids know."
you know, I was like, "Yeah,
it's 'cause in Instagram
"I was talking about TikTok."
There are certain humans
that go around earth
that have admiration
from different sectors.
Truly the people that I most admire
for their creativity in storytelling
that are my contemporaries,
friends, acquaintances.
If Brian's ever brought
up, their reaction to you
and how they admire you and
your storytelling capabilities
reminds me of what like a 17 year old
like flipper of eBay feels about me.
So it's a fun way to start.
So everybody Brian is here.
I'm gonna let him introduce
himself like I always do
and then we're gonna
get into a conversation
about why he wrote a book,
considering where he's at
and what he felt he wanted to say
and then we'll take a call from Instagram
so put your phone numbers
in, Katie we'll grab that.
But Brian for the couple of people
that don't know who
you are on this podcast
please tell them who you are
and what you're about.
- Okay, my name is Brian Grazer
I accidented into the media business
into the storytelling
business, it wasn't a plan.
I didn't really know much about
movies or television at all.
I grew up very very very middle-class
in a little cul-de-sac in Sherman Oaks
and now all off a sudden--
- And real quick, 'cause I love to jump in
and they are gonna be mad at
me for cutting you off already.
What did you play, as
a six to 13 year old?
Like what kind of kid were you?
You were like sports, were you drawing?
Were you selling?
Were you lemonade stands, washing cards?
- I didn't do lemonade
stands, I would sell magazines
all types, Life Magazine,
National Geographics
like lots of other kids, baseball cards.
I did a, the Valley News And Green Sheet
which was a newspaper, voluntary payment.
I was literally delivering papers
to get no payment, zero.
So you have to knock on the door
and go, "Hi, my name is Brian Grazer
"I deliver your Valley
News And Green Sheet
"I know it's voluntary
"but would you consider
paying me for the month?"
And I'd get like 50% of them.
- How much of that selling
in that kind of environment
do you think later helped
you sell through ideas?
- Tom Hanks, when he learned
I delivered the Valley
News And Green Sheet
and because he is a master of all details.
He said, "This is the perfect thing
"you're the perfect producer
"that's what they have to do
"sell sell sell sell sell
"knowing they're always
gonna get baseline no.
"How are you going to treat that?"
And I used to say, "As
a producer, no to me
"is just a temporary point of view.
"I'll soon change that." (laughs)
- I love that.
So you were that kinda kid?
So you played sports, you sold stuff?
- I played sports, I sold stuff.
I had multiple paper
outs (mumbles) just said.
I was a champion for the underdog always.
Probably 'cause I felt
like such an underdog
in the classroom itself.
So in the classroom, I had acute dyslexia
I couldn't read a word.
So I couldn't, certainly
I couldn't read a sentence
none of the words lined
up, you know, cohesively
or sequentially, I couldn't read at all
and so therefore it
caused me a lot of shame
because I would have to try to avoid
all this sort of shame
that would come with it
so I would look away when
the teacher looked at me.
So I'd never look at anyone
in the eyes in class.
- I know that game very well.
- Were you there?
- You know, I never was diagnosed
but my ability to consume
information through reading
or my ability to read out loud.
If you ask me right now
to walk across the street
to go to Madison Square Garden
and talk in front of 35,000 people
on a dime?
(finger snaps)
I would do it so easily.
If you asked me to read the
back of this Ken Griffey Jr.
I'd be like, literally
sitting here announcing
"Don Drysdale pitched the
first no-hitter for the."
Like, that is like not comfortable for me.
- I understand. (laughing)
- So I very much understand
that and back to your point
never wanting to get called on
since I knew no answers to anything.
Nor did I ever wanna read in class
was something I mastered as well.
- Yeah, so probably you did things like
invent having to go to the bathroom
when you knew it was coming
at you, you know, question.
- I invented everything to avoid.
- Yeah, okay, so we did it all.
We did all the same stuff.
- Not going to school at all
like being homesick
(Brian laughs)
because I knew there was
an unavoidable situation
like, the big test.
Yes, I did all those things.
- That seemed to work for you nonetheless.
- Yeah, but you know what?
It's an interesting starting
point to this conversation
because I think, right now we
live in a parenting culture
that tries to fix everything
and I think all the
advantages are from adversity.
- Yeah, me too, I totally agree.
- There's a lot of people
watching right now that, you know
listen, everyone has their
strengths, weaknesses
shortcomings, happiness's
but like professionally
you and I have had nice runs.
And I genuinely think a whole lot of that
has to do with not being good at school.
- For sure, I agree with you.
- Period.
- Because it causes us to be self reliant
where in kids now and I have kids
they become disempowered.
- 100% and you know what
happens with disempowerment?
Unhappiness
- Unhappiness.
- And what happens with unhappiness?
- 'Cause you have no identity.
- Depression.
- And so everybody wants
to blame social networks
for all these bad things
that are happening to kids
without taking a look at themselves
of how we've completely made these kids
completely not be accountable
and need us for everything.
- Yeah, that's a really good point
you know, because, you
know we kind of know
that we're in this epidemic right now
of loneliness and drugs
and no human connection
all that stuff, but I never thought of
I never really focused
on the parental side.
- It's the answer, in my opinion.
- I think you're right, I--
- I think we have a
contemporary parenting problem
that tells children by our behavior
that you're not capable.
Let me go take care of this
I'm gonna run to school--
- Solving problems for your kids.
- Like yes.
- My wife, Veronica, who
is sitting behind me.
- Yep, I see her.
- She says, I do, unfortunately,
I bet you do this too
I do this with my employees.
When I see them, they go
"I don't know how or what you do."
I just go, "I'll do it."
I just do it.
Do you do that?
Are you better than that?
- I don't do that
but I definitely create
entitlement in different ways
which is, I'm actually
taking on the core pressures
which eventually, I had a
interesting period in this company
several years ago, where I
had to reset a little bit
because I did create entitlement.
From not micromanaging,
'cause I don't micromanage.
I don't create a whole
lot of accountability.
We just lost a fortune,
Andy text me this morning
that we've lost a lot of
money on this thing we sold
and I'm like, "How's that possible?
"It was super profitable."
And he's like, "Like the two
people that were closest to it
"misjudged what we were doing
"with the people that
were shipping with it."
And like my reaction
and I was even, "What?"
'cause I'm really being trying
to be thoughtful about this
I'm like, man, what makes me awesome
is I'm like, "Cool, next."
(Brian laughs)
- Right.
- That's awesome but at some other point
not creating Radical Candor
to the people that are
involved with me, like hey.
Like I'm trynna find my
balance and evolution
because to your point, I'm just like
"I got this, don't worry."
It doesn't mean anything
in the scheme of things
which can lead to entitlement.
What I don't do though,
which is the nuance
of where we got here, is I want
the market to be the market.
I don't handhold anybody about anything.
I don't do the, "I'll do this."
I want them to do it
and I'm willing for the whole
thing to burn to the ground
so that they can understand
that that's how it
and that's hard for a lot of people.
- Yeah, that would be hard for me.
Yeah, that would be scary, to walk, yeah.
- I would like companies to project--
- But it's good advice, by the way.
I'm gonna try it.
- I'll tell you what your
advantage is, you know?
Like, I'd rather have a
major project completely fail
and have it be my loss,
so that they understood
that they couldn't do it.
Which is where I know
exact, that's where you go?
What's cool about where
you're at at this point
is setting it up from the beginning.
Anyway, we're getting super side tracked.
(laughing)
We still haven't gotten to the punchline
of where a lot of people
like, "Oh, that's that guy."
How did your career go?
- Okay, so basically it was
like this, couldn't read
total avoidance of people,
shame, everything else.
On the playground, what was I like?
I protected kids that were bullied
and I protected one kid, I remember
right near at the jungle gym.
A kid that was two years older than me.
I was scared of this kid but I fought him
and surprisingly won.
And I thought, you know
what, I can do this.
And I felt finally felt
the feeling of winning
at something, so I just--
- And was the school like stunned?
- The school was stunned it was--
- Was this like massive upset?
- Yeah, it was a pretty emotional thing.
- Clearly.
- The school was really stunned
and I became like the man.
I really did, it was.
And that happened all the way
through high school, actually
and then kids got really big.
- Right, you know what's crazy about that?
I can't believe we're talking about this
and I'm side tracking
even though I promised
myself I wouldn't right now.
I think we need to bring fighting back.
(laughing)
I have literally brought
this up the other day.
- Meet you at the handball courts' thing.
- I got into five actual fights
by the time I was in sixth grade.
Nobody fights.
- No one fights, no.
Nobody gets fight at all,
I wouldn't know anything.
- I think we need fighting to come back.
There's nothing crazy about a little scrap
where somebody wins and loses.
- All right, I hear you,
'cause it's all about you.
It's about like are you
gonna survive or not survive?
There's a lot of things involved.
- I think we need more school yard.
I mean I literally fought--
- You're gonna get a lot of
comments on this episode.
- I'm very aware.
I literally was like,
literally had in sixth grade
against Oded Weinstock,
that was the kid's name
Oded Weinstock.
- Wow, that's a name.
- Like it was like a,
3:00 p.m. at Marco's house
across from the ice cream truck
and the whole school knew.
Like the whole day, the
fight was getting promoted.
Like I was Dan Kane or something.
(laughing)
- That's very funny, that's cool.
- So you won this big fight?
- So I won this big fight
that became a part of, a
very big part of my identity.
In Junior High I was able to read.
Not well, kind of like your trepidation
without reading that baseball card.
Anyway, I was able to read.
So at that moment in time
I started really looking at people.
I did just exactly the opposite
and I started looking at people
and realizing, wow, I
can learn so much more
by actually looking at them.
So not only am I reading some stuff
which would be kind of a
ancillary sort of educational tool
but the real educational tool
is, like face-to-face communication.
Really being present looking
at someone in the eyes
not staring at them in some weird way
not trying to think of 20 questions
but just like--
- Listening.
- Listening, yeah.
Like letting that evolve
and I found that by
face-to-face, human connection
I could ask questions
and really learn a lot.
When you look at somebody
they have a tendency to trust you
they have a tendency to feel
validated as a human being
like, this guy really cares.
And because of that, people
will really let it go
that they will give you
their heart and soul
and you give them your heart and soul
and a lot to be gained.
So that was the point of
why I wrote this book.
'cause I found that I can--
- And lets tell everybody
the name of the book.
- The name of the book is called
"Face To Face: The Art
Of Human Connection."
- And you thought this
at an incredible time
because this is your superpower
that you learned early
and now it's a counter-cultural
move to a technology world.
Like it's so in the zeitgeist right?
You knew that so many
people would here and say
"Oh my God, I need that
"or my kids need that or
my executives need that."
'cause everyone's demonizing technology.
Like I think it's perfect timing.
- Yeah, I think they're so compatible.
I mean, search is very
compatible with human connection
because, I don't think you should
know nothing about somebody.
Unless you're just needing
but I think, you know,
when you're going out
to meet somebody, you should learn some.
It's proper to learn something
about that human being.
- You know what's funny about that Brian?
I often say that technology for me
is the gateway drug to the face-to-face.
- [Brian] Oh very good,
I've felt similarly.
- I think there's a lot of
people who are more old-school
who are like you and I,
that love face-to-face
that completely shit on technology
and think it's an either or.
I'm like, "No no no, I have
way more human interactions
"than most people because I use it."
But I'm a little bit different
I actually don't research
anything on people
I meet for the first time.
I use social media to meet
people, we talk a little bit
and then we'll have a meeting.
I like coming in cold
'cause I like listening and
watching, the same way you do
and I feel that if I do reading.
That I'm taking somebody
else's perspective
and I'm already hedging my own observation
based on somebody's two cents.
It's amazing how little
I know about most people
when I meet them, even very fancy people.
Because I don't know a whole lot
I like that restaurant that
we met in the first time
of course I've heard your name
but I wouldn't have been able to know
as especially 'cause I wasn't Holly
I didn't know a lot about the
whole Hollywood ecosystem.
I liked what I felt.
- Yeah, that's interesting.
The funny thing, Okay, first of all
I love everything you just said.
I think it's a--
(laughing)
No I do, it's amazing.
People say how do you, you know
how have you started such great talents
or given them a break or
how do you pick writers?
I mostly pick people
just out of their aura
their energetic aura, that
to me is the number one
sort of a litmus test for
me, do I feel their energy?
Is that feeling right?
And then I go deeper, but--
- Let's make this fun for the audience
from a content standpoint.
Give me some hot takes,
on first time you met them
the world didn't know who they were
now a lot of people know.
Give me a couple anecdotal
like person and what you
felt in that first meeting?
- Jeez, okay.
Well, I'm gonna cut back to Isaac Asimov
he's the most prolific science
fiction writer in the world.
I was dying to meet Isaac
Asimov, I met he and his wife
I flew across the country from
LA to New York to meet him
I didn't have a lot of money
and within the first five
minutes (clears throat)
His wife said to him, "Isaac,
I don't think he knows
"enough about us, I
think we should leave."
So that wasn't a good situation
but I learned, in my case I learned
and so I learned, you know,
that I probably shouldn't.
I think they might have detected a truth
they might have detected,
he doesn't know enough
and I'm probably radiated that.
That was probably living within my aura.
- What was the context of the meeting?
- Well the context was,
there was a point in my life
through 35 years, where I
still do this every two weeks
reach out, do a cold call to meet somebody
that's expert anything other
than what I do for a living.
So it could be science,
medicine, politics, religion--
- What did they think
when you reached out.
Why did they say yes,
from your perspective?
From your perspective.
- My perspective is, most people
when they're out of alignment, you know
like their agendas are out
of alignment with yours.
They might just revert back to the fact.
"Well, the guy makes big movies."
and therefore it's possible
they can enlargen my message.
That's always sort of latent in me.
- You know where I'm going
with this series of questions?
- No.
- The level of audacity
to make that statement, from
her, is I'm fascinated by.
- She did it though it was--
- Yeah, no, I'm aware she did
it, you just told me the story
I'm always fascinated by the level of--
- It's very audacious--
- To say, "Were leaving."
- Correct.
And for me it stems from
a seed of insecurity
that leads to that audacious act
and I was more curious of like
what could have led to that?
What did she think you were extracting
that you know, like--
- [Brian] I don't know.
- I'm very fascinated by
bad behavior, is really interesting to me
because I am unbelievably
empathetic to hateful people
because the level of pain that
is actually happening inside
to get to bad behavior, is extreme.
I think we hate on hate
and I'm empathetic to hate.
- [Brian] Interesting.
- Which is not a very popular
point of view right now
everyone just wants a fight in our society
and I actually think the
unlock to betterness.
Is to understand why somebody can even get
like why would somebody do that, you know?
The people that I have come across
and I came from a very
Eastern European family
there's a lot of dynamics there.
The weakest, seem the strongest.
That seems like a power move by her?
It's a bullshit move by her,
I think it's a weak move.
- I'm sure you are right, yeah.
Well you study a lot of things
that I, some things we overlap
on and that's interesting
I don't--
- Anyway, so you learn
from that, you took that--
- So that was bad
(laughing)
That was really bad.
Okay, Norman Lear, amazing.
He just exudes, he's 98 years
old, he exudes goodness.
I met him 40 years ago
when he was like the king of everything
and I just had lunch
with him again last week.
- What about somebody
that, a writer or an actor
or a producer, or whatever
that, this was their break
that you gave him the break
and what do you see in that moment--
- Bradley Cooper.
- Good, that's good, let's go there.
- Okay, so check this
out on Bradley Cooper.
Because he's such a big deal now.
I mean, he's a, you know
Oscar nominee, everything.
Anyway, Bradley Cooper--
- Motherfucker can sing.
I mean, he could rave it.
- So Bradley Cooper--
- He's uncomfortably handsome.
Let's just get to the
punchline, so go ahead .
- It was at least 15 years ago
but he remembers this super well
and he brought it up to
me only just recently.
But basically, he was
late to a meeting with me
and he thought, "Brian
Grazer, like I can't be late."
He's out of breath, he's
starving, he's in my office.
I could tell he's hungry
because I was eating in
he was supposed to be, I'm
eating a tuna fish sandwich
a giant one from Nate and Al's
and I say, "Why don't
you eat half of this?"
He goes, "No."
I go ahead and insist, he
goes, "All right, thanks."
He gobbled it up like bang.
Now, smash cut, he's
Oscar, winning everything.
- What did you feel in that meeting?
- I just felt like it was the
humane thing to do, he was--
- No no no, not from your
perspective, I apologize.
Like what didn't you take from it?
Like, "I think this kid's got something."
Or he said something interesting
or who introduced you.
What's interesting and you
were curious about that
I would say that's an interesting one.
- Somebody introduced me or made him
heightened my awareness to Bradley Cooper.
- Had he been in that random,
"Sex in the City" episode yet?
- Oh my God.
- You, like that?
Can you sub the Vee.
- Tee give me something, I'm
sneakier than people think.
- Geez, you are sneaky.
- I am sneakier than people think.
- How you can get that,
where does that come out?
Where in your vocabulary?
- I am a weird dude,
I pick up random shit.
- So I don't know, I feel like am sorry
you got me, stumped me on that one.
- So that was the one that you recall?
- Yeah, I just wanted to meet him.
Because it was a good-looking--
- How about you and Ron?
- Ron Howard, amazing.
- When did you guys meet?
- The reason I partnered with him.
There was no evidence he
could be a director, really.
There was like no empirical evidence.
I was just yelled out of
my window, I was a producer
I was 26 years old, 27 years
old, on the Paramount lobby.
I just produced some really
big movies for TV at 25.
Like one was the 20-hour
miniseries on the 10 commandments.
So I sort of got, like
people were, you know
thought this guy's got something
so now I've got something,
I've got a big office
I yell out the window,
'cause I see Ron Howard
he's the actor on "Happy Days".
(laughing)
I go, "Ron Howard, hey."
I think it scared him,
'cause he kind of ran away
and then I called his office and said
"Hey, I just yelled out to Ron Howard
"I know this is his office, can I meet?"
I sort of organized a meeting.
He came up to my office,
like three or four days later
and he just came in, I
almost felt like a glow
like the glow of the sun,
coming in at me close up.
Like just a glow of goodness
and I thought, "Wow."
It was such a unique
feeling, energetically
to experience and to accept.
And I thought, everybody needs goodness.
This is the guy I'm gonna bet on.
- That's awesome.
- And he would tell it that way.
Then I bet on the right guy
because he too became an
Oscar-winning director
and he's so incredibly gifted
but neither one of us knew that much
about each other at the time.
- Is the book out, or it's coming out?
- The book comes out in, I think the 17th.
- Of September?
- Of September, sorry yes.
- Of the people that have
read it, in your inner circle
that think that it's interesting
it's always hard to get
inner circle feedback
'cause it's so vested, but has there been
you know, one thing that I
knew about us, that was similar
and we brought it up here
and I remember leaving the
restaurant the first time we met
at your house and things that nature.
We are very similar in the way
we read people in that way.
I know that you would pick up
on this, if you've seen it.
Has anybody who's in your inner circle
said something in a unique
way or something unique
that has given you an early insight
to something that you're excited about
that you may not even realized
when you were done with the book?
Has that happened yet?
- Yes.
- Good.
- Where people go, "God, you wrote a book
"that's like a pathway to success."
Most of it is just telling stories
that accessed an eye content.
- Did you have a ghostwriter?
- I did.
- Of course--
- Here's what happens, I
had somebody, I did and--
- 'cause I've written, five New York Times
bestselling books and Stephanie
Land is my ghostwriter
but the way I do it is, I just
sit with her for 30,40 days.
She records everything and
makes it into proper grammar.
Not a word in there is hers.
- Yeah, okay, so this is
what happened with us--
- And I think a lot of
people do that, like I do
but they're cautious to
say they have a ghostwriter
because when we hear a ghostwriter
that's what I thought before I get it.
You think, "Oh, Katie wrote it
"and I'm slapping my name on it."
Like, I literally read and I hate reading
my own books multiple times, in case
God forbid, there's some word
that I felt like, I might have said like
serendipitous and she said randomly.
(laughing)
- So we had a publishing date
and then I said to my wife
you know, the publisher likes it
people are liking it and Veronica read it
and she said--
- It's garbage.
- "I don't think it's very good."
Yeah, I have an expression,
in making movies
'cause every one of the
movies that have flopped
that I've made, 'cause
I've made flops too.
- What's your biggest
flop, from your perspective
it doesn't have to be financially.
Like you would say, "You
know what, fuck financially
"I knew there was something special here."
I love that you're looking at like.
- Oh I'll say, Okay,
"Fun With Dick And Jane"
with Jim Carrey.
- Explain why.
- It still made $100 million.
- Forget about that.
- You know, it was still
a hit, 'cause I probably--
- But you thought it
should've been a billion?
- I did "Liar Liar", "Giant".
- I'm aware.
- And I wanna give some, in
case somebody's listening
you know, here.
- They can Google, you've got
that plenty of double use.
- Well, mostly it's
about Jim, you know like.
For example, it just was shitty.
I mean it was--
- Why?
It was kind of a shitty idea,
it was an old-fashioned idea.
I guess, you know, the
superstars got excited about it--
- Let's go different way.
And this is a fun question.
- It just wasn't good
I was embarrassed.
I use it as, when I say
something to my kids.
They go, "We're gonna put
on 'Dick and Jane' dad
and they know, like that's
just so embarrassing for me.
Anyway so--
- Brian, real quick, not to interrupt you
but I'm dying--
- Because I rationalize, well the point is
is that, anytime I make a
decision, that's a good decision
that means it's shitty.
Every decision has to be excellent.
If it's not excellent
and I go, "Good enough."
It always turns into shitty.
- Let me ask you a random
thing in the other one.
This is a fun question,
I really want you to
I hope there's a real answer to it.
What film or show, honestly did way better
than you expected it?
'Cause we're all humans.
Even in the 100 point scale, you're like
"Oh, this is gonna be an 82."
And then it was a 130, in reverse.
'Cause it's easy to say
I fucked this up, right?
Reverse, like deeply, like, you know
you never had to publicly say like
"Oh shit, this is that big, I
thought it was gonna be okay."
- Oh that's so great.
- That's a good question, right?
- That's a really good question.
No one's asked me that
question ever, no one.
Very good, GaryVee.
- You know why, 'cause it's
an interesting question.
I know that you thought things
that then did better, I
mean it's just the truth
it's just the way it actually works.
- So you wanna know,
which movie did I think
was gonna not do well--
- Or by the way, it might have been a hit.
It might have been a smash hit
you thought it was gonna be a hit
it's your biggest one of all time.
Or, you thought it was
gonna be C and it was a B+.
- I have a few of those for sure
but I'm gonna give you the--
- The biggest one.
"Apollo 13".
Because what happened
is, we got really into it
Ron Howard, Tom Hanks
and I and we all thought.
Everyone knows the ending, how can this do
more than $40 million, literally.
- Was the number you were
running or in your head.
- That was the number, we bet
we all wrote on a little piece of paper.
The highest number
was $40 million.
- Of the three of you, right?
- It was 40.
- Was that yours?
'Cause you're the most
optimistic as a salesman?
- Yeah
- I knew it, go ahead and?
- Well did like almost 400
and it got nine Oscar nominations.
- We know what happened
- But so we were just like totally shocked
we didn't realize it
was gonna become like--
- Why did that movie happen?
Do you remember?
- Yeah of course I do.
It happened because there was
a little 12 page treatment
that Jim Lovell, the
actual astronaut wrote.
I got it and I thought
wow, this is like a
great story of survival.
Because I'm really fascinated
with human capability
and I thought, here are these guys
they're all on the level of
human capability, level 10's
all three of them and this event occurs
that challenges that level 10
and causes them to think,
we are not gonna make it.
How do we summon something inside of us
to get us to survive, when we
don't think it really exists.
So I just thought, in the
world of like human capability
with highly capable men,
that's what happened.
And I thought that was pretty amazing.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, so that's what happened.
I mean, of course it did really well
but I thought there's no chance
this is gonna do more than $40 million.
- When did it open?
December?
- 1897.
- Do you remember?
- Ow, in July.
I didn't realize this, 'cause we don't
plan movies for release times.
It synced up with NASA's
celebration of the 20th anniversary
I think.
- Which was nice.
- Yeah, which was nice, so that, we had--
- All right, so Veronica says this is shit
and so what do you then do?
- So she says it's shit and then I go
I don't know what to do,
I can't revisit this.
I can't say I hate this thing already.
She goes, "I'll help you."
And so for a year, she
plugged in she helped me
and really did quite a
bit, to say the least.
- You know what's crazy about that
like having people plug
in, I've said this publicly
but I've never really gone all the way.
I always love talking about how I passed
on Uber twice, in the Angel round
and cost myself like, you
know, half a billion dollars.
And if you read my first book, "Crush It"
that kind of put me on a map.
The only person I thank,
besides my family is Travis.
Travis was in between
things, just hanging out
flying around the country,
going to conferences
and in Vegas with me and
AJ, just hanging out.
And he was like, "Hey, let me read it."
And truly out of all my books
the only thing that
has ever been affected.
It's not Stephanie land
though without her
constructing there is no books.
But Travis gave me a lot of feedback
of like, "No, but you say, you say this."
And so I understand that dynamic.
- Yeah, oh good yeah.
So that's kinda how it
played out, so it was great.
It was great, like my wife
helped me, it was awesome.
- What are you hoping
people get out of it?
- Well, I'm hoping that
people get out of it
that anyone could do this.
I was a total solid F student, solid
- Do you think deeply
introverted people can do it?
- Anyone can do this.
- Okay keep going.
- Anyone can do this,
because you don't have to be
in other words--
- What's stopping people
from not being good at--
- This is how people screw
up on public speaking
People are terrified of public speaking
if you think to yourself, this is a gift
thank the audience, be generous--
- Why do you think people are scared
of public speaking, so much?
As like one of the core.
- Shame, shame in front
of a lot of people.
Their fear of being embarrassed.
- Do you think that that
gets to the higher level
of the concept of actually
worrying about other people's judgment?
- Yes. (laughing)
- This is the shit I'm
spending all my time on.
- That's a really good, that
is the most important thing.
- Lemme give you an example.
You and I as creative people.
Do you understand that
kids are growing up now
with TikTok, YouTube, Spotify.
Like, do you understand that
everybody can create now?
At scale?
- Yeah I do, I do.
- At a level that is so unprecedented.
There were so many gatekeepers
when you got in the Hollywood game
that had to say, "Yes you have a chance."
Now we all have a chance
and yet people are still
not making content to live their happiest
and dream-filled life, out
of an anonymous comment
that says they're ugly.
- Yeah.
That's crazy.
- So I've been thinking a
lot about public speaking
and social media, because I'm
obviously remarkable at both.
(laughing)
And what I figured out was
something quite ridiculous.
My over-indexing, without jokes now
in both those categories
actually leads to the core super power
that the DNA in parenting I was given was
which was, I have such
internal self-esteem
noise from the outside
by the way, it's also why I have humility.
I don't hear the cheering
which allows me to not hear the booing.
I believe that parents
are over cheering kids.
People then become
addicted to the cheering--
- That's a great subject.
- Which then leads them to
be crippled by the booing.
- Yeah, I agree.
What you just said was
profound, I love it.
That's why I say, the great
ones in the media, our business
they go, "I don't read the good ones
"I don't read the bad,
I don't read anything."
The great human beings to me
you know, the really self actualized ones
they're the ones, just
like the way you just said.
It's where you're not reliant
upon external validation
- And I'm hoping that people
care more about their legacies
because it leads to better micro behavior.
- Yes it does.
- My depth of caring
about what's said about me
when I'm dead, actually leads to me being
a dramatically better
human while I'm alive.
And most people are like, "Well
I don't care when I'm dead."
They want the short--
- But I think you and I share this
I think we're both pretty karma oriented.
- 100%.
- Because I definitely feel like
you get the tip on the
jump ball on everything
if you're nice to people.
- The end.
Because I think there is nothing--
- I love how you talk it--
- No, but you know what's funny Brian?
I actually think, you know why?
- Tell me
- To that point.
I actually think the single most practical
thing I know on earth, is karma.
And most people think it's
the grayest, fluffiest--
- I agree with you though.
- It is singularly practical.
Do the right thing, be kind.
It is so clear to me that
that's how the world works.
- Just the physics of that works.
It works that way for you
where the energy is working
for you instead of against you.
The winds to your back--
- Final thoughts.
What do you wanna leave
everybody who's listening
about this very entrepreneurial
and creative crew
which I think really
fits, listen by the way
these are a little bit
tighter than I wanted to be.
So I think Brian and I
are gonna do this again.
- Great.
- For everybody
who's listening, I'm gonna
give you guys a good point.
Something that I know my audience
has not heard from me often.
As you guys know, I tend not to publicly
cosign a lot of people.
Mainly because I don't
really know that many people.
I do know people, but
I'm scared to be like
"Follow this or care about that."
Because I don't, I'm not in control.
But once in a while, back to probably
the weirdness of our relationship.
Like, it's so obvious to
me, that the same value
and I don't know what you're putting out
or what documentaries
have been made of you
or what content you're putting out.
But for my audience,
Brian's earliest points.
We obviously are different,
like everybody is.
I have an intuitive feeling
that something that I bring value to.
The reason you're even listening to this
there's an overlap, I will never read
three pages of Brian's book
and I easily know that it
could bring a lot of value
to the majority of my audience
and that's not throwing a
right hook for my buddy.
I don't think we've seen each other
in three fucking four
years, like really really.
We have warm feelings, but like
this is bringing value to you.
I know the book is probably--
- Thank you
- Not you, them.
- Them, of shit, sorry
- You'll be fine, whether it sells
one copy or eight billion.
I have a feeling that what is attractive
and has brought value
to much of my audience.
There's probably nuances
from a different perspective
awarded differently than my click
at the cost of $13 to $16
over there, fuck the
discounted Amazon prices.
So I'm gonna give that real cosign
I have a funny feeling for a lot of you
there's a build here.
And for the ones that actually learn
through actually reading, I
think this will be a good one.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome Brian, I
believe that, I really do.
It's very--
- It's opened up every door for me
I've learned everything--
- Can I say something cra--
- Every one of my movie
everything that was successful
in my life came from this.
- This is actually a
little bit weird for me
and in a weird kind of like
the world speaking to me.
I have been spending a lot of time
personally in the last year
realizing that I should be
making film and television
and just sitting here
with you, I'm like right.
This is a talent game.
Like in the same reason he
would have been talented
at all the things I ended up doing.
Like, I understand human
beings and human truths
and then I will naturally
find those stories.
I understand why Spud
Webb story is a good story
it's because it's against
all odds five foot five guy.
It's just a bigger story than
the Ap, like the Apollo parts
the literal, it's the gray.
- [Brian] Yeah yeah, it is.
- "Blindside", the second I saw it
I'm like, "This is gonna smash."
A left tackle, fucking football player
that's the stupidest pitch of all time.
But the bigger story was obvious.
It's why "Star Wars" is my favorite thing.
It is the most universal fuckin' story.
Which is the fine line
between good and bad
is thinner than you think.